you know I read a lot about the founding
fathers but really they don't do much hi
I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Jackson cool a reason
contributor a freelance journalist and
the author of the new book Samuel
smedley Connecticut privateer Jackson
thanks for joining us who was Samuel
smedley Samuel smedley was a Connecticut
native who signed on during the American
Revolution at the age of 23 to be
lieutenant of Marines on the state ship
defense for the Connecticut State Navy
and less than a year later he was the
captain he went on he took a total of
fourteen prizes during his career was
shipwrecked captured by the british
twice the second time he was actually
taken to England and imprisoned from
where he escaped into France so he
worked for the Connecticut Navy and each
proto stayed under the continental
congress had its own military and then
there was also one that the federal
government for lack of better word with
continental congress chartered what what
did the connecticut legislature charge
him like give him the permission to do
originally the ship was intended for the
defense of the seacoast for the defense
of the Connecticut shoreline
particularly after the Battle of
Brooklyn Connecticut was surrounded the
British Navy were in Narragansett there
in Long Island and they were in New York
so Connecticut was surrounded on three
sides and originally they did they went
out and took three scottish transports
in boston boston harbor but later that
didn't pay because of that money from
those transports went to the naval
office we're just kind of disappear and
just to be clear privateers basically
what he was told is that you go at and
you kept your ships and you get a
certain you know you get to keep a part
of what you you and your crew gets ripe
a part of whatever you you raw right so
the difference between a privateer was a
ship that was outfitted at personal
private expense and what would happen is
generally they didn't pay anything to
the government so what would happen was
when they brought a prize in it would go
to the Admiralty court if it was judged
to be a good prize and not piracy it
would be liquidated the cargo sold the
ships
and for privateers how they generally
divided it was it would be fifty percent
for the owners and the investors and the
remaining fifty percent will be divided
among the officers and crew and divided
into shares now what the Continental
Congress did was for their own Navy they
had set down rules in the beginning the
the Continental Congress would get
two-thirds and the crew would get
one-third on merchantman but they later
change that because they had to compete
with the privateers because if you're a
sailor you'd rather go on a ship and get
fifty percent of a prize rather than
thirty three percent of a price so they
changed that in October of 1776 where it
was half on merchantmen and then they
would award one hundred percent to the
crew for ships of war because they knew
that they weren't we're going to go
after the Royal Navy so I mean
essentially the thus mentally story is
partly a story about competition among
armies or among military forces to say a
really different ways right so and but
what happened was Connecticut had
originally followed the continental
congresses model but after that change
they did not follow suit so they stayed
on the two-thirds one-third model the
state got two-thirds of the prize the
crew got one third and what happened was
smedley couldn't recruit enough men for
defense and the other state ships as
well because again everybody wanted to
go either in the continental or the
privateer and get fifty percent of the
prize and that helped lead to his
ultimate death right he couldn't get
enough men to get out of the harbor
every voyage he's constantly having
problems until finally he's at off New
London because he couldn't go to the
Caribbean to catch the merchantman which
he had been doing very successfully and
to his benefit and to the benefit of the
state because they were getting some of
that money and he was off New London and
he wrecked on a shoal right outside New
London in Long Island Sound this I mean
is a it's a small story on a certain
level of the of the Revolutionary War II
Europe but it's evidence pretty
fascinating and it lays bare this really
interesting dynamic about how do you
properly compensate people who are
fighting for freedom or defending you
etc which is really just it you know
interesting as hell to think about
Americans are always told
that we don't care about history we
don't know anything about history but in
fact historical books books about people
like you're talking about I agra fees
etc are always among the most popular
what is our interest in history and you
know what what can we do you know what
what's the kind of eternal lessons that
we're looking for from history I think
because there's just so many stories out
there that you know you find like this i
found i just came across a reference to
smedley and as I began reading more
about it I was like this is an action
movie why hasn't anything I've never
been written about this and there's just
there's just countless of these stories
out there that just nobody has had the
time to discover and investigate you
know for me what I liked about this was
that you know I read a lot about the
founding fathers but really they don't
do much I mean they talk a lot they
write a lot of letters but it's even
even Washington wasn't really you know
in the thick of things whereas you know
somebody let me read about this who's
got cannonball screaming by his ears
right and you know they're boarding
ships and you know its pistols and
cutlasses are you gonna try to turn this
into a Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise pirate I London I would
definitely love a movie and a franchise
well good luck with all that and I think
as a result of this interview reason
gets fifty percent of that price right
nay nay 33 okay well well we'll go with
that for a reason TV i'm nick gillespie
we've been talking with jackson cool
author of samuel smedley connecticut
privateer thanks again
you